[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the first bonus
show of 2017 we are back uh yeah it's
good to be back a lot of things happen
politically a lot of things happen i had
an interesting trip Pat had an
interesting trip I guess we'll start
with we'll start with my trip so a few
things number one I flew from Boston to
London where I was I I went there for a
week for the end of the year break uh on
an airline relatively new airline
release new to the Boston Market I don't
know if I think there it's a new airline
generally called norwegian air shuttle
and it's kind of like an international
low-cost carrier uh and it ended up
being really really good they fly uh for
this direct Boston to to London route
they flied the brand new Boeing 787s
which really are fantastic planes and I
don't know if you followed it all Pat
the development of this airplane and the
whole concept of the 787 is it's not
continuing to go bigger and bigger like
the Airbus a380 this is a plane that
it's it's a two engine plane so it's not
like the huge 747 a380 the idea being
that it's more advanced it burns far
less fuel and it's a much more
comfortable ride and uh it doesn't the
cabin doesn't get nearly as dry as on
most planes the windows are like
two-thirds bigger uh the lighting is
much more it's much less harsh is it one
of those planes that have the two seats
on the side three in the middle and two
on the other side or is it just a three
and three smaller plane no it too it's a
wide-body so it's two two aisles yet a
wide-body long-haul plane and uh it was
a really good experience is the first
time I'd flown in one and I could not
say better things about norwegian air
shuttle nor about the Boeing 787 very
interesting to see sort of it that
fundamentally changing air travel air
travel has been the same for a while but
it's definitely different it yet if I
sit on a normal plane for seven hours
for example although this flight was
only five and a half from Boston to
London but
he met a seven hour flight uh when I get
off of it my lips are super dry and you
just feel dehydrated and it was
noticeably different on this plane and
is because it's sort of pressurized to
not be at like the seven or eight
thousand foot altitude that most planes
are pressurized to and that may cause
you to faint we've learned too well yet
you had to make sure to keep yourself
hydrated not to have any alcohol before
the trip no yeah I did not faint on the
way there or back and I was very
stressed about it people remember on my
flight back my last vacation was in
Italy on the flight back and eight and a
half hour flight I fainted about halfway
through well we determined I was clearly
very dehydrated uh and that I had
alcohol on the plan is did everything
wrong and this time I was drinking so
much water I must have gotten up to go
to the bathroom probably eight times
during the five and a half hour flight I
me was crazy I just didn't want to take
any risks with the hydration uh but I
was fine fortunately there was free
meals too because they've kind of phase
those out on the domestic flights at
least you can still kind of get them
when you're going across the yes they
still had they still had uh meals meals
included uh they actually served smoked
salmon bagels for breakfast what was uh
I mean as far as airline food goes
pretty good with a cream cheese and
capers cream cheese and capers yeah I
mean they had the full thing yep no
doubt about it so okay that was really
great now as far as culture and cuisine
in London cuisine okay London not known
for its cuisine and the the as I
mentioned sort of on the show the
British pub food had fish and chips a
couple of times how many times am I
really going to have fish and chips uh I
had some of the different you know I
mentioned on the show I did the
afternoon tea thing with my girlfriend a
couple times it was cool but it's not
really being in Boston where you have
10,000 Irish pubs which have menus that
are quite similar to much much of what
the British pubs had the British cuisine
was not an exciting part of the trip
what was great though was the Indian
food I mean just the best indian food
that I've had of course India uh was was
a British Holly and you saw free foot
not free flow but significant
immigration and just the best indian
food I've ever had in
london and many people i've mentioned
that you said oh it's the best there
yeah and uh indian food for the most
part is good for my diet too so i'll
have to check out the next time I go to
London Union I even had indian breakfast
food which is what well I mean I don't
know this was supposedly Bombay style uh
Indian breakfast food and so you know
the naan bread which is like a common
Indian bread they take the naan bread
and they scramble eggs and sort of wrap
it inside of the naan bread and then
give you a spicy sauce that you put on
top pretty good yeah that sounds
fantastic I know the the British cuisine
is not the best by itself so you should
you definitely should go to the indian
places the asian places etcetera
absolutely now as far as culture goes ok
it was very comfortable to be in London
but much of that is number one shared
language number two living in New
England it looks just like being in New
England to be in the surrounding area of
London now London of course is a really
big city so that's not exactly like
being in New England other than in
cities but you've got all the same town
names we've got a bright in here right
here next door they've got a Brighton
we've got a Milford they've got a bad
news is it's all the exact same names of
places they speak the same language the
weather was very similar so in that way
it felt much less like being in a truly
foreign place that being said and this
is not me being preservative in any way
I feel like and I'm curious to hear from
you because you've been to some of these
places I feel like I find more
interesting the more Mediterranean
European culture of Spain and Italy and
France I don't know what your experience
was yeah I get that because it's much
different and if you're going to a
foreign land you want to take in those
differences yeah but I'm not too sure
that the weather is is quite similar
between here and London because when i
think of weather in London I think of
consistently cloudy yeah overcast you
know just a little bit chilly but always
consistently you know 50 60 degrees uh
here you could have it be 80 degrees one
day and forty the next it'll little
ping-pong back and forth that you're all
different types of weather I guess what
I mean is it the weathered might during
my entire trip there was almost
identical to what it was in Boston
before I left which is about yeah 40
five degrees and a lot of cloudy days so
sort so to speak so even weather wise
didn't feel like I've been transported
to a different place right you gotta
feel like you're getting away on
vacation right but overall it was great
really enjoyed it got to visit my cousin
their pictures of him and I on on my
Instagram a david pakman really really
good trip and uh if if uh I would go
back I would want to check out some of
the smaller towns I sort of have a
curiosity about Liverpool which is
almost as far as you can be from London
all the way on the north coast of
England um I've some curiosity about
that I would love to check out like
Oxford and Cambridge but alas who knows
when I will next be back there it was
your first time there my first time yep
I never been there alright so Pat had
what I'm calling the excellent adventure
road trip where he drove all the way
down to Florida you want to explain sort
of like what you did and then you flew
back at the end of the trip yes so I've
never gone on a road trip that long
before I want to do that epic adventure
of a lifetime what was the longest
driving that you had done before
Washington DC okay so like eight in a
half hour eight hours yet this was
something that's going to be split up
across multiple days I guess you can do
it when one shot if you want to drive
twenty four five hours in a row that's
that's not in the spirit of a road trip
no it's a healthier no it's not um so
the first day we drove down to New
Jersey State at a friend's house in the
North Carolina State at a friend's house
Charlotte was one of the cities that i
visited and I was not too impressed
really Charlotte seems like it has the s
skyscrapers but only because it's
obligated to have skyscrapers because
it's a city it's very spread out it's
very rural I was expecting a little bit
more from Charlotte I've never been
other than to the airport so I can't
really say I did but needless to say so
what would be the key thing about Boston
that you like better than Charlotte I
did I mean there's history here it's a
coastal city which I like a lot more
yeah um you know I didn't take in too
much of the city they have this like
epicenter strip mall kind of area I love
straight in the center of the city but i
think that was their main attraction
yeah i don't know what else they have
there but you know i wasn't i wasn't
feeling Charlotte okay fair enough
continue down to the rest of the trip in
Florida State in Jacksonville which is
probably not the best place to stay
overnight in sight seeing remember when
Lewis called in to
the bonus show a couple weeks ago he was
in Jacksonville own I'm or heading to
Jacksonville he also said it was not a
great place for him to bed and run into
another continue down the eastern coast
of Florida down Palm Beach you stopped
on beaches the whole way it was it was
fantastic yeah Miami is an amazing city
I'll imei wanna go back I mean it it
combines all my favorite things of
beaches and warm weather and yep
beautiful buildings and architectures
and I still have the benefits of an
urban area of lots of great restaurants
and museums and all of that type of
stuff and it's remarkably not too
expensive too again we were able to stay
at hostels for 40 bucks a night I was
hearing that uh the average rent I don't
know what the average rent but you can
play it you can stay at a place on on
South Beach for you know a comparable
price to some living since um
neighborhood in Boston is that right yet
maybe a thousand dollars a month through
twelve hundred dollars a month yeah very
good deal alright cool I mean calling
that I mean you know because our
audiences so spread out they might hear
twelve hundred dollars a month very good
idea what are you talking about that's a
very good dealer you have to keep that
in mind uh continue the journey down to
Key West cuz why not i think it's the
southernmost point in any continental
United States and I I was expecting more
from Key West to maybe I have the same
criticisms as Charlotte but I know it's
a it's a very small um very small town
there's maybe 30,000 people I thought it
would be a little bit more quirky uh but
they didn't seem to be too many people
around it was 75 80 degrees so maybe a
lot of people were staying home rather
than going to the beach is right and
that's not the weather that they used to
and that's not really beach weather for
them yeah uh but it just seemed like we
drove all the way out there and there
was too much to see but I mean the
florida keys are nice i went back up the
west coast and finished up the trip in
venice okay yep that's so was though is
the west I've I've only been to
individual places in Florida is the Gulf
Coast driving hole is it does it feel
like a totally different place than
going down the East Coast highways um I
don't know if it's it it seems about the
same but you have to cut across the
Everglades which is pretty fantastic uh
I guess there's two ways across the
Everglades one is an interstate highway
i think it's 75 and then there's just
the florida state highway which is a in
it which is just route 41 and that that
highway is the one we took in it's just
one lane the whole way it's it's just
great for you know at least a couple of
hours while really starts the drain on
you you don't see much of anything yet
if you if you're going there around
sunset or after dark I mean good luck to
you that's that's a tough trip and then
you know just in comparisons I think I
think western Florida or the Gulf Coast
I think they would say it's a lot more
older uh you know the average age
there's maybe 60 or 70 the east coast of
Florida is where you want to be I think
that's where the nightlife is
interesting did you so when I thought
about doing a road trip the longest I've
ever driven has basically been six hour
trips so uh Boston the Montreal is one
example another one is Boston to
allentown pennsylvania and I think that
was actually even less i think was six
hours with stopper to uh and I I like
driving i consider myself to be someone
who likes driving but I get very bored
when I'm just done along Highway trip
because then it's I don't even feel like
it's really driving it's just basically
you put on cruise control and you're
just passing the miles one after the
other so when I've thought about doing
road trips I thought the way it would be
interesting would be to drive one way
and then just to fly back that's the way
we did it yet other people say well if
you come back a different way than you
go then it's just as interesting coming
back then going I don't know I feel like
when I know that I'm on the return that
I would just start getting very fatigued
and bored with the driving you're
absolutely right and after you know
spending a week pretty much having all
of your stuff in your car it gets to a
point where you just kind of want to go
home yeah just being on the way back
we'll put you in a mentality where
you're just not enjoying yourself yeah
you're done seeing the sights time to go
home any like car related issues that
happen when you drive that long that
people might not think of if they're
just drive short distances I mean you
definitely want to have a reliable car
this this is a maybe a few years old and
had about 25,000 miles on it yet all the
the latest gadgets on it girl for your
backup cam the blind spots up cuz yeah
yeah when I mean when you're adding up
that many hours of driving it is quite
dangerous I think about it because
driving is inherently dangerous you're
going to do it for you know 30 hours 40
hours a lot of times without breaking
for you know hours at a time it can be
kind of dangerous so Boston to jersey
was what four and a half hours yeah i
would say about for now and then jersey
to charlotte was how long it's hard to
it's hard to remember maybe five
it really seems like a be lot now I
could be longer I mean it's it's all
melting together so maybe was closer to
eight nine yeah yeah and then Charlotte
you went straight to Jacksonville that
was the next stop which really wasn't
that impressive in terms of covering
ground on a road trip but I we got
sidetracked a little bit and was
actually picking up a friend to bring
him down to Miami to so as we wanted to
stay in a city before we got to him uh
any problems with veganism during the
trip you gotta be prepared I had a whole
cooler stuff i mean staple foods is what
you got to bring peanut butter loafs of
bread bananas nuts all that stuff and
yeah I mean it's tough when the only
rest stops are places like McDonald's
yeah I mean what are you gonna do you
hate the fries canada fries as we know
the fries have got beef in them yeah so
you went very prepared very prepared you
ought to be true interesting very very
all right there is Pat's trip up that's
it for today we'll be back tomorrow the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]